homme ok u hippopotame pas stavsky
faire ce que l'opération ira
maintenant la parole ne permet pas la moindre
slip Rostov a parlé de moi avec
le président a besoin d'un moyen de s'en sortir
liquider
[musique]
[applaudissements]
pour l'homo à la chouette
le mien dit oui, je suis dans ton bureau
étiquette de sauvegarde de service diaphyse zinger
levure et chemins
maintenant besoin de résultats très rapidement
peut l'ouvrir
[musique]
je connaissais quelqu'un de talentueux qui
soudainement engagé
absolument pas expliqué et la pêche
comment les bouchers se sont signés
un verdict qu'elle
tu couches avec elle
[musique]
frère ou elle peut tout faire pour
miséricorde union joseph lanterne led
c'est 0
que fais-tu
enlever les lits, mais seulement le cocher je
désir tu dis peut après le plus
vieux daryl
la passion du grille-pain le répète
lourd
Tryna les imbéciles ne peuvent pas entendre
Alexey a enveloppé le jeton de dépôt encore
taille mais dossier secondes pour catturny
et la berline avik est juste ma soeur
Tempête De Neige
je suis une drôle de chanson
maintenant et je l'ai rendu
croire . javi loin qt
entreprises
[musique]